here with the very latest is the ranking
member of the house judiciary committee
congressman jim jordan along with former
white house chief of staff and former
congressman mark meadows is with us um
you know
both of you were very very pivotal in
exposing this big abuse of power
corruption scandal all right mark
meadows
add this new technology
couple it with what's going on in israel
and how potent this is how how all
freedoms can be taken away
and christopher wray who
never cleaned up the fbi is buying this
technology
well obviously the the biggest thing
sean is is that our founding fathers
wanted to make sure that search and
seizure is done under a particular
format and when you start to look at the
ability the technology that is out there
right now
congressman jordan
hit this many many years ago actually in
the oversight committee when he was uh
serving there
when we start to look at really what the
the technology is able to do it is very
very frightening and you mentioned prime
minister bibi netanyahu and some of the
reporting uh that surveillance has taken
place there uh it shouldn't happen in
america and quite frankly we need to
make sure that we have safeguards
whether it's a member's office as it has
been alleged with the capitol police or
whether it's private citizens
with this new technology jim jordan this
is a massive corruption scandal in
israel and i see the same thing here why
would we believe for one second that the
very people that knew that this was a
non-verifiable dossier they knew hillary
paid for it they were warned off it
numerous times then when the sub-source
even told them that none of it is true
they still applied for more fisa
warrants to spy on than president trump
uh why would we trust them with this
type of technology until they clean up
their house
no you're exactly right the same fbi
that spied on president trump's campaign
the same fbi that set michael flynn up
four days into the administration set
him up in the white house that same fbi
which we now know is spying on moms and
dads who simply had the audacity to show
up at school board meetings and speak
out against this curriculum that same
fbi the leadership of it now has this
amazing technology which should only be
used on terrorists that's our concern no
one has any problem using this on
terrorists our concern is are they going
to use it on us we know what they've
done to parents putting a threat tag
label on parents so this is frightening
and i would ask a simple question sean
what if peter strzok had this four years
ago you know peter strzok who said i can
smell the trump supporters at the
walmart what would he what would andy
mccabe john brennan have done with this
technology four years ago that's what's
frightening and that's why we
this is so concerning what happened with
what the fbi is purchasing and the the
the situation with congressman nels i
would like an answer to what
director ray if republicans get back to
congress which i think hopefully they
will in november would you start an
investigation
congressman jordan
oh we
yeah we got to do colin we got to get to
the bottom of this whole doj
fbi going after parents i mean we had
but for that whistleblower coming
forward and telling us they are putting
this threat tag designation on parents
are they going to use this spyware
technology on the same parents who now
have a threat tag label on them so that
is definitely something we got to get to
the bottom of and a whole host a whole
other number of investigations that we
also have to uh we also have to have uh
you know i could think of a lot of good
uses it was so bad mark meadows it got
to the point that for national security
reasons i supported the fisa court but
because they didn't clean it up i can't
in good conscience support it any longer
because they never got to the bottom of
it they never held the people
responsible accountable
so the message is the deep state can
pretty much do whatever the hell they
want and it'll be there'll be zero
consequences and there's no way this
will not be used for nefarious purposes
well you covered this in in your
monologue you said that 99 of of normal
fbi uh personnel are are honorable
public servants in the and it's probably
99.9 what we need to make sure is some
of those who have actually used the
system to uh
make a political point or or actually
violated some of our civil liberties
those are the ones that you're talking
about that we need to make sure of but
let me let me just be very clear we are
on a fast page
pace technology wise that will will all
of a sudden enter in all kinds of
dynamics that the courts have never even
looked at you know if you can have
spyware that's actually on your your
cell phone that collects all kinds of
data
can you imagine
unseeing things that you've actually
been able to collect
we need to make sure there are civil
liberties are protected each and every
day uh regardless of of that and you
mentioned the fisa court we need to make
sure that we use them just for the bad
guys abroad and not on u.s citizens well
it's a simple basic fundamental right
it's a constitutional right you don't
have justice if you don't follow the
rules
jim jordan mark meadows thank you both